nous sommes ici au milieu du plus grand
foisonnement de vie que l'on puisse
trouver à la surface de la terre
une vie qui se déploie dans la voûte de
feuillage surplombant la forêt tropicale
dans cet environnement on découvre la
plus grande diversité d'animaux et de
plantes qui se puisse imaginer
et cela grâce à deux sources
essentielles la chaleur et l'humidité
l'association de ces deux facteurs a
créé la jungle qui s'étend comme un
anneau autour de la terre une vaste zone
verte brisé à certains endroits
cette jungle se situe en amérique du sud
elle s'étend sur près de 1000 kilomètres
au nord et au sud de l'équateur
elle est encore largement inexploré
l'arbre sur lequel je suis juché est un
cap au pied il ne grandit pas en groupe
c'est un arbre solitaire et il
appartient à la plus haute variété que
l'on trouve dans cette jungle
il peut atteindre 60 m
si le feuillage du reste de la forêt
peut être comparée à une mer verte
le sommet du kapokier émergent tel une
île à sa surface
une île qui bénéficierait d'un climat
particulier car il y avait ici plus de
soleil et surtout il y à du vent un vent
pratiquement inexistants dans les
profondeurs de la forêt des grands
arbres qui émergent tels que ceux ci
existent dans toutes les forêts
tropicales tout autour de la terre il
abrite les oiseaux les plus féroces de
la jungle
l'aigle harpie en amérique du sud
l'aigle couronné en afrique ou et celui
ci l'aigle des singes en malaisie ils
patrouillent à la surface du feuillage
plongeant à l'occasion pour saisir un
écureuil un sage ou à un autre oiseau
ces règles ne produisent qu'une seule
couvet qu'ils doivent s'alimenter
pendant presque une année en descendant
des hautes branches ensoleillée du
kapokier on abandonne la brise et le
soleil pour rejoindre un monde différent
ici les réchauds chargé d'humidité à
peine troublé par une légère brise
par dessus comme si elle faisait un
écran aux rayons du soleil
des millions de feuilles forme d'une
voûte en mosaïque qui capte un maximum
de lumière
beaucoup d'entre elles beaucoup de ces
feuilles ont une sorte de juin la base
de leur tige qui leur permet de pivoter
suivant la course du soleil
c'est un monde clos la plupart de ses
habitants y sont nés et ne le quitteront
jamais les insectes sont omniprésents et
il semble qu'il ne puisse y avoir de
limite la variété de leur forme et de
leur couleur certains sont la proie des
autres la plupart tirent leur
subsistance des arbres collecte les
graines boivent le nectar est la sève
mangent les feuilles ses terrasses verte
constitue le pâturage d'une multitude de
créatures comme celle ci le saïmiris ou
singes écureuils d'amérique du sud
ces régions ne connaissent pas de
variations saisonnières comme milan
n'existe plus au nord pas d'époque
précise pour la chute ou le
renouvellement des feuilles pas de
saison particulière pour la floraison
dans cet été perpétuelle de certains
arbres fleuriste ou les dix mois tous
les quatorze mois voire parfois tous les
dix ans mais ce rythme est loin d'être
le fait du hasard car tous les arbres
d'une même espèce fleurissent à peu près
en même temps afin de se politiser l'un
l'autre
la brise sous la voûte de feuillage
étant très faible on ne peut compter sur
levante pour assurer cette pollinisation
celle ci dépend des insectes ou d'autres
animaux à qui les arbres fournissent un
abondant festin de pollen et de nectar
de graines diverses les oiseaux
accomplissent une bonne part de ce
travail ils ingurgitent des fruits il
digère leur chère île évacuée propage
ensuite les graines
la nuit d'autres créatures prenne la
relève
les chauves souris sont généralement
insectivores mais est sous les tropiques
certaines espèces ne mange pratiquement
que des fruits
les arbres sont taillés de nombreuses
façons le ouistiti est expert dans la
récupération de la sève les dents de sa
mâchoire inférieure qui sont dirigés
vers l'avant lui permettent d'en
provoqué l'écoulement en raclant les
corses
bien que l'air soit pratiquement
immobiles ils transportent les sports
microscopique des fougères et des
mousses qui se loge dans les corses des
arbres et qui germe
elles fleurissent puis leur reste
s'accumulent pour former un terreau sur
lequel d'autres plantes vont pousser
leurs racines pendant tu captes
l'humidité de l'air et leur branche
deviennent de larges balcons charge et
d'orchidées et de broméliacées
parmi ces dernières figurent les anna
dont chacun abrite sa propre colonie de
locataires
non
la rosette de leurs feuilles forme un
calice toujours rempli d'eau un endroit
très apprécié des animaux qui peuplent
la voûte et qu'ici des haltères
certaines grenouilles l'utilisent même
comme une véritable pouponnière cette
petite reine est arboricole ou
dendrobates se déplace avec son têtards
frétillant sur son dos humide
elle doit maintenant lui trouver une
pièce d'eau pour lui permettre de nager
et l'antre dans la rosette à reculons et
le têtard peut se détacher d'elle est
plongé certaines espèces de dendrobates
considère qu' à ce stade
elles ont définitivement assuré leur
responsabilité parentale il est en effet
probable que des moustiques soit venu
pondre à proximité qu'avec un peu de
chance le têtard trouvera à se nourrir
de leurs larves
mais cette grenouille ci ne prend pas de
risque tous les trois ou quatre jours
elle retourne sur chaque plante où elle
abandonnait 1 et ares et y dépose de
nouveaux et non fécondé qui vont fournir
aux têtards leur nourriture
en attendant qu'il soit suffisamment
développé pour attraper eux mêmes un
insecte
pour ces grenouilles comme pour beaucoup
d'autres animaux de la cime de la jungle
celle ci constitue un microcosme
suspendu à la surface de la terre
quelques mètres carrés où elles sont
nées vive et moureaux en descendant de
cette voûte végétale
on laisse derrière soi la partie la plus
peuplée de la jungle pour pénétrer dans
une zone intermédiaire fait de lier
année de tronc dénudées cette couleuvre
paradis s'y déplacent verticalement
l'angle d'inclinaison de ses écailles
ventrale lui fournissant une sorte de
crémaillère mais elle bénéficie d'une
caractéristique encore plus inattendu
en contractant ses côtes elle transforme
son corps cylindrique en un véritable
ruban elle creuse le vende qui devient
une sorte de parachute enfin par des
ondulations elle réussit à diriger sa
chute
et dans les forêts de bornéo
on trouve deux meilleurs planeur encore
cet écureuil volant ou paix tories
présente une extension de la peau qui
relie ses poignets et ses chevilles et
forment un parachute
dans cette zone médiane de la forêt
tropicale d'amérique du sud
la plupart des mammifères se déplacent
d'arbre en arbre le long des lianes les
tamarins sont capables de progresser par
bonds d'un mètre environ en toute
assurance loi car il n'est pas aussi
athlétique qu'il s'est vite la fatigue
du saut en projetant son corps d'avant
en arrière jusqu'à ce que le balancement
de l'arbuste sur lequel il se trouve
le transporte sur l'arbre le plus proche
à mesure que l'on rejoint sa base le
tronc de cet arbre immense qu'est le
capotier s'épanouit en vaste contreforts
et arc boutant qui le stabilise car ses
racines sont peu profondes
en fait le seul de la forêt n'est pas
fertile
cela est dû notamment à l'important
filtrage de la lumière par le feuillage
de la voûte et aux pluies torrentielles
qui draine la plupart des éléments
nutritifs contenue dans le sol
ainsi comme les racines de la plupart
des plantes qui poussent ici celle du
kapokier doivent trouver leur
subsistance en surface dans la couche de
feuilles mortes qui recouvre en
permanence le sol les processus qui
engendre ce terreau sont très rapides
l'humidité est élevé la chaleur l'êtes
aussi
et ces deux facteurs réunis accélère son
pourrissement
les bactéries
les moisissures les champignons
prolifèrent étendant leurs filaments à
travers tous les districts
il imprègne entièrement le tapis de
feuilles brise les tissus et restitue au
sol les engrais qu'ils contiennent les
racines peu profondes des arbres les
capte rapidement les champignons eux
mêmes se développe d'abord le pied puis
la tête répand dans leur sport dans tout
l'âge à même le sol de la forêt est
jonchée de débris d'arbres de tron a
battu deux branches arrachées par les
orages de feuilles mortes tombent en
pluie régulière
c'est ici que les termites trouvent leur
nourriture là prélevant particules après
particules pour l'emmener et l'a traité
dans leur nid leur travail incessant
comme celui des champignons est un
maillon important de la vie de la forêt
car les termites remettent en
circulation les engrais qu'ils récoltent
sur le sol peu d'autres créatures
peuvent ingurgiter des feuilles et des
bois morts mais beaucoup d'entre elles
mangent les termites et il est un autre
habitant la forêt qui sait faire un
usage varié de ce qu'ils y trouvent des
êtres humains vivent ici depuis des
dizaines de milliers d'années les oies
aura ni de l'équateur font partie des
derniers peuples avoir conservé le mode
de vie primitive des peuples liés à la
forêt tropicale
les chasseurs communique en utilisant
les arcs-boutants des arbres géants
ces coups sourds sont perceptibles à des
kilomètres car dans la forêt où la vue
se limite à quelques mètres le son est
le meilleur moyen de communication les
animaux de la jungle utilisent également
ce système pour affirmer leurs droits
territoriaux et pour appeler leurs
compagnons dans chaque forêt tropicale
mammifères saint paul comme champion de
chant à madagascar céline dry en
amérique le singe hurleur et dans le sud
est asiatique le gibbon le siamang qui
amplifie sa voie grâce à un énorme sac
situé sous sa gorge et qui lui sert de
caisse de résonance à parmi les gibbons
le cri le plus puissant les familles
s'interpellent l'une l'autre
par delà les vallées
la jungle est un biotope stable le vent
étant absent la température et
l'humidité sont quasiment constante même
la longueur des jours sous l'équateur ne
varie pratiquement pas le site est
presque inchangé depuis des millénaires
les montagnes ont été érodées par les
glaciers les plaines se sont transformés
en des heures les lacs sont remplis de
boue et sont devenus marécages la jungle
elle n'a pas changé depuis plusieurs
millions d'années et cela peut expliquer
l'extrême diversité des plantes et des
animaux qu'on y trouve
c'est comme si cette ancienneté avait
permis aux forces de la nature de
produire des créatures à vivre
éternellement dans cet environnement
immuable
où
la fertilité de la jungle ne dépend pas
uniquement de l'ensoleillement mais
aussi de la pluie et nulle part ailleurs
celle ci ne tombe aussi abondamment que
sous les tropiques
l'orage est précédé par un vent violent
qui pendant quelques minutes fouette les
grands arbres et secoue la voûte de la
jungle des normes gouttes commencent
alors à tomber lentement d'abord puis à
torrent
un véritable déluge
à certains endroits le sol est envahie
par des flots tumultueux qui s'écoule
entre les arbres vers les rivières
l'orage a donné à boire aux assoiffés
il a fait tomber des fruits qui vont
nourrir les affamés et qui permettront à
d'autres de faire des provisions
l'orage a aussi apporté la mort aux plus
âgés
un capot kg ans est tombé il n'était
peut-être plus très stable d avant
l'orage et sans doute at il été
déséquilibré par la chute d'une de ces
énormes branche le poids de l'eau
supporté par tant de feuillages était
plus qu il ne pouvait supporter la mort
du vieil arbre donne le départ à une
course dont les concurrents sont les
jeunes pousses qui se pressent sous les
débris des branches
elle était destinée à végéter par défaut
de lumière maintenant elles pourront
s'épanouir apparaîtront d'abord des
arbustes qui dispersera ensuite leurs
graines vers d'autres clairière un an
après les jeunes arbres les dépasserons
hauteur à mesure qu ils s'élèveront
serta ralentiront leurs courses
seuls un ou deux accompliront la fin du
trajet et atteindront le soleil ils
étendront leur branche
une nouvelle fois la jungle s'assombrira
et la voûte verte sera reconstituée